[Music]
hey my man
can I help you
let me get all the grass
no I ain't sounding an autographs but
you get off my car
oh holy
you don't remember me huh
come a long way from bumming rides from
your mom
damn
boy hey you had you had you had me
Damien
just got back to the hood stop by the
old gym but uh yeah we upgraded a couple
years ago
see
damn this is a minute
in a minute
stay focused Jazz Jabs give it to him
yo man
just trying to do Herman like that oh
man we caught a little man
oh no that was intentional you handle
this
are you talking what happened we doing
my job hey come here man
okay use your head leave all that other
mess outside
I told you I wanted
so miss producer when's your next show
I don't really perform like that these
days
yeah I took a break because I was I was
having some issues with my hearing on
stage and now I'm trying to be careful
and preserve what I got left so I'm
producing
not anytime soon
still hard to get that part up though
right yeah it's not the only thing I
love but it takes work
it take your name
they give you a number
that's how it start
what was the best though
yeah you were
I was bro
but I never got a chance to prove that
look all I'm saying bro
follow creep
take a chance on some Underdog
why can't you
brought you into my home bro you met my
family
I put money up for you
put the gloves on your hands that's
enough really
you put the gloves on my hands
oh
you must be Punchy
the memory serves you used to carry my
gloves get your [__] and get out the gym
hello
[Music]
is there something else you want to tell
me
foreign
up at some point I don't know what else
to tell you I need to understand what is
going on some sad story you're trying to
feel sorry for me I don't want to feel
sorry for you I want to understand you I
want to know what is going on
I don't want to talk about anything
I've been trying to forget it
it's Dad leave it leave it let it vibe
I'm talking about that [__] no more
you figure out your [__] Dee because
what cannot happen is her seeing you
like this
do you understand
the higher you get the harder it gets
[Music]
that's life
because this is a war
as the fight it's a battle
so
how long have you known each other
[Music]
it was like brothers
my name came back the past came back too
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back no friends
[Music]
before I got locked up I was the best
you a coward bro and a fraud try to
spending half your life in a Cell
watching somebody else live your life
store that little brother
I'm coming for it all
it's not gonna stop
down this Creed you're the best pound
fighter in the world
three years ago it's been a minute since
you've been on these streets when I
walked away from boxing I walked away
with some unfinished business
[Music]
you see that man right there
do you remember him hey
hey
you hit us up
don't let him destroy everything you've
found
everything we've built
yeah
I need you to start fighting
all right
Adonis Creed has been defined by boxing
his entire life but it's boxing all
adonises how do you raise the bar for
the man that we've gotten to know
throughout crew one and Creed two and
really take his franchise to the next
level
going into Creed Three Adonis is a
father a husband a better man but his
secrets from his past his family doesn't
know
hey my man can I help you you don't
remember me huh
to tell a story that honored the legacy
of Rocky but was different a big part of
that was introducing Damien Anderson how
long were you locked up 18 Years bro I
know I've been away a long time but I
still got gas in the tank
come by the gym
thank you
donus and Damian have a real past they
grew up as children together in a really
tough environment who cares what
happened with you too it was like
brothers I was the best though but I
never got a chance to prove that they
shared this box in green together so
imagine what happens when you have to
watch someone live that dream without
you it can breed resentment Damien was
like family hey hey what you doing man
are we past talking then maybe you just
have to fight
disagree with me I had a Clear Vision of
what I wanted this story to be I grew up
with Adonis Creed so this opportunity to
direct their installment it's so
personal to me getting to see Mike
approach directing and almost athletic
way was incredible to watch good working
with Mike it was a real collaboration
and when you feel that trust it's the
best gift an actor can have
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people this is a movie that
lends us up to that big screen
experience
fights the action do you want to see
that up close and personal I'm coming
for everything you threatening me
it's all on the line here
All Roads live up to this moment and we
need to see what happens next
[Music]
thank you